welcome to Sky Studios in West London
tonight the final two candidates hoping
to be the next prime minister will face
questions from conservative party
members and from me I'm Kate Burley this
is Mrs Trust of course and Richie sunac
as well good evening to you both for the
next 90 minutes they'll be answering
questions from some of the people who
will decide their future this is the
battle for number 10.
[Music]
good evening and welcome to the battle
for number 10 the struggle for voters
between Liz truss and Rishi sunat comes
to a head tonight here at Sky News for
weeks the candidates for conservative
leader have debated but only now are the
people who'll pick them finally getting
the delayed chance to vote the backdrop
a country predicted to be about to
plunge into recession it really is make
or break tonight we have more than 60
conservative members and others in our
audience largely reflecting the
demographic makeup of the party many of
them are still undecided over who to
back in a format that's different and we
hope perhaps we're Illuminating than
other events the two candidates will
separately face questions from the
audience and then face mine in an
extended in-depth interview we tossed a
coin before we came on air
who won
Liz trusts one and she chose to go first
she is with us now are you happy with
the good good evening it's nice good
evening thank you it's great to see you
are you happy with the format I'm very
happy ready for the first question yes
excited here we go let's start with our
first question and that is Diana who's
here on the front row good evening Diana
what's your question my question for Liz
is the Bank of England have said that a
recession is inevitable what could you
do to mitigate the impact of this
well what the bank of England have said
today is of course extremely worrying
but it is not inevitable we can change
the outcome and we can make it more
likely that the economy grows and what's
important is first of all that we need
to help people struggling with the cost
of living I would immediately reverse
the National Insurance increase I would
also have a temporary moratorium on the
green energy level to save people money
on fuel bills but I'd also keep
corporate corporation tax low to make
sure that we are attracting investment
into our economy and doing all we can to
avoid a recession because I know what
it's like when people lose their jobs
when towns and cities across our country
struggle I don't want our country to go
through that that's why it's so
important we keep taxes low and we do
all we can to grow the economy by taking
advantage of our post-brexit freedom
unleashing investment changing things
like the procurement rules and doing
things differently but now is the time
to be balls because if we don't act now
we are headed for very very difficult
times are you happy with that I am
that's good to hear thank you okay
anybody else going to follow up on that
one for us
nobody at this stage was just warming
you up still aren't we okay well I've
got one you're confident that you'll be
able to avert a recession by the end of
the year well what we know at the moment
is a resection is predicted by the bank
of England and what we need to make sure
is we're using all the tools at our
disposal keeping taxes low doing the
reforms we need to to our economy to get
growth going faster to encourage people
to set up businesses to encourage
businesses to invest and I want us to be
on the side of people who work hard
people who do the right thing people who
support their families people who set up
businesses and that's why it's so
important we don't burden them with
excess regulation but that we also keep
taxes low under the current proposals
our corporation tax would go up to the
same level as France and 10 points ahead
of Ireland and I really worry about our
capacity to attract that investment into
our economy if we do that you simply
can't tax your way to growth and I'm
afraid the very high taxes we have at
the moment a 70-year high are likely to
lead to a recession okay and that's what
the bank of England is predicting
my question is I'm amongst very few in
my age group and ethnicity that are
actually members of the conservative
party I've been speaking to some of us
and we are afraid that the party has
lost credibility so my question is how
will you repair the damage to the
party's reputation well the most
important thing is we deliver on the
Promises we made we got elected across
the country in 2019 because of our
Manifesto we said we'd unleash
opportunity that we would grow the
economy that we would keep taxes low so
we need to deliver on all of those
things we need to deliver on the
opportunities of brexit and when we
promise something we need to follow
through on it I think that's really
important but I also want the
conservative party to be a party that
reaches out to everybody across the
country gets new people on board
encourages people to join our party
because we've got some fantastically
talented MPS but we need a new
generation of members and I would
appoint a really strong party chairman
to encourage that to happen any clues
I I have not I am definitely okay not
being premature we're still in the
middle of a leadership race and what I'm
about is about talking to our party
members about my policies for government
but what I can say is I would always
make sure I appointed people to my
cabinet on the basis of merits and
people that get things done because what
people really want us to do is deliver
and we've only got two years it's not a
long amount of time and we need to get
started straight away so I want people
from all parts of the party from all
parts of the country who can really get
on and deliver okay politicians always
say that our party is a broad church and
I always point out to them that people
die in Broadchurch
[Laughter]
uh has got a question for us hi good
evening Liz I'm a medical consultant
um I work in our hospital and I see day
in day out the Relentless pressure that
our medical staff is having now under
Staffing is a real issue at this moment
in time if you become the next prime
minister how will you solve this
well first of all the NHS has done a
fantastic job in covert but we are
facing a huge backlog and that is
putting huge pressure on first of all I
make sure we're putting the recent
funding we allocated the 13 billion into
social care because there are many
people who are in hospital who ought to
be in Social care but there aren't the
beds available so I'd first of all make
sure we're investing the money in Social
care I'd also support our doctors and
nurses more by removing some of the
Central dictats and also having fewer
layers of management I've on the
campaign Trail over the last few weeks
I've met people who face seven or eight
layers of management above them and I
think that can be quite difficult and
quite demotivating and what we need is
more of the uh more of the empowerment
more of the decisions to be made by
people on the front line there are also
a number of others issues we need to
look at like doctors pensions I've met a
lot of doctors who've gone into
retirement because of the specific
issues around their pensions I need to
sort that out and also there are many
doctors who very kindly came out of
retirement to help during covert you
know help with the vaccination Program
help with the real issues we face in our
hospitals and what I'd like to do is see
what we can do to encourage those people
to come back into the profession and
really help because we do face serious
issues it is difficult to get a GP
appointment I represent a rural area
we've got real problems with ambulance
waiting times as well so we need all
hands on deck but I really believe that
it's by trusting people on the front
line trusting the professionals more and
making the organization a really great
place to work that we will actually
solve these problems together
I will say that I know that the people
that I work with will be really really
happy if you looked into pension tax
because a lot of people are going into
early retirements exactly I'm sure that
will help bring the waiting list down
and uh um you know help the road for
Recovery as well so thank you thank you
but but we also need to listen to people
like you who are actually involved in
the Health Service and listen to your
advice because what what I've heard is
lots of areas where we could use our
facilities better so for example I met a
doctor who told me that he wanted to go
in and work at the weekend use the
equipment to the weekend but actually
he'd been banned from more senior people
in the organization from doing that so
there are things like that that I think
we can Empower people to do things
differently and really treat this as a
major national program to to deal with
the aftermath of covert we were very
successful at dealing with covert
getting the vaccine rolling out the
vaccine but now we have a major issue
with an National Health Service and we
need all of the best brains working on
it just clarify are you suggesting that
you should sack layers of management no
I'm not what I'm suggesting is that we
need to deploy people in the National
Health Service better and what I have
heard so I'll keep them there's been a
lot of there's been a lot of targets at
centrally by the Department of Health
and NHS England and I want things to be
decided more locally so there's less
distance between the people making the
decisions and the people actually on
Frontline lots of people want to ask
your questions Miss trust I think David
from Guilford David where are you hand
up David where is he there he is he's
just here David you've got a question on
Ukraine I believe I have I thought it
was going to Rishi I must admit oh well
but I'm I'm perfect
how would you propose to broker peace
negotiations in Ukraine as opposed to
continuing to provide arms to prolong
the state of War
well the only way this war will end is
when the Russians leave Ukraine and we
need to make sure that we enable the
ukrainians to defeat Vladimir Putin if
there's any failed peace settlement if
there's any giveaway of Ukrainian
territory what we know from history is
Russia will just come back for more we
saw that with the Minsk Accords which
didn't work and we know what Vladimir
Putin's plans are he said that he wants
to create a greater Russia essentially
the old Soviet Union including the likes
of the Baltic state so that is why it's
so important that we were the first
European country to supply weapons to
Ukraine and we need to continue to do
that but we also need to work with our
allies like the Americans who are also
putting weapons into Ukraine we also
need to toughen up the sanctions on
Russia because at the moment the way
Putin is able to fund his appalling war
machine is because the oil and gas
revenues that he's getting and so that
means us finding alternative sources
particularly in the UK we we have the
North Sea we can invest in more nuclear
but it also involves other countries
finding alternative sources as well
because what Putin has done is he's used
Europe's dependence on Russian gas to
hold the whole continent to Ransom and
that is appalling and we know the end
result of what happens when dictators
get appeased is that every inch of
territory that's been taken since 2014
well I certainly think it would be wrong
for us to give away any territory on
behalf of the ukrainians now of course
president zelenski It ultimately is the
person who has to determine what an
eventual peace deal would look like and
he has been very clear that Russia needs
to leave the entirety of the Ukrainian
territory but I think it would be
completely wrong for the United Kingdom
indeed any other country to say Ukraine
should give up part of their territory
that would be very wrong and what I
worry is the lesson it would give to
aggressors around the world if Russia
was seen by saber rattling by Landing up
lining up troops on the border lining up
tanks on the border then successfully
gaining a piece of Ukrainian territory
sure what message would that send to
others around the world it would be a
terrible message and the long-term
threat to Global Security
no I just wondered if you didn't mention
anything about attempting to negotiate
or broker some peace deal
the
we have been involved in working on
negotiations with our American French
and German colleagues and we are
providing support to the ukrainians to
do just that but it is ultimately about
what the ukrainians are willing to
negotiate what I don't want to see is
Ukraine be put under any pressure to
give up territory for expediency's sake
because I'm saying it simply won't be
expedient because all we'll see is
Russia Retreat and then come back for
more later and they still haven't given
up their Ambitions to take the whole of
Ukraine it was a tactical Retreat away
from Kiev not a long-term Retreat and we
need to be very very worried about
Putin's intentions it's one of the
reasons by the way that I favor raising
our defense spending to three percent of
GDP over the next I've got lots of
questions to get through so if I may
know not at all I want to bring in our
next question which is about housing and
it's from Jude from Chippenham and I've
wanted to say this all evening Hey Jude
okay thank you very much
um hello France secretary I've recently
graduated and will be moving to London
to start a new job as a commercial
lawyer
when I made the decision I thought
perhaps naively that it would make sense
to buy somewhere in London rather than
rent
but that was before I saw the cost of a
deposit on a starter home
how will you
solve the housing crisis and make it
easier for young people to own their own
home
Jude I think it's incredibly important
that we help more people get on the
housing ladder it is a problem that this
generation of young people end up buying
houses much later in their lives than
previous generations but the way to do
it is not the system we have at the
moment which is soviet-style top-down
housing targets which simply cause huge
concern and don't actually deliver the
results we want and I've before I became
an MP I was a counselor I sat on a
planning committee it was hours of my
life I'll never get back because because
we didn't have any control over what
happened everything got overruled by the
planning inspector in Bristol so what I
want is a much more localized system of
planning so in London for example I
think there's more opportunity to build
up in London to build more you know
higher story buildings I think in other
parts of the country what we need is
more investment zones where we have
industry developed alongside homes
alongside infrastructure and that can be
determined by local people but the one
size fits-all planning system we have at
the moment simply doesn't work the other
thing I do to help you specifically is
when somebody does rent they should be
able to use their rental history towards
getting a mortgage for their home and
that will help people who are long-term
rental renters get onto the housing
ladder okay just want to share this
quote with you
um that you I think it was three years
ago perhaps a little bit longer we need
to build a million homes on the London
Green Belt near Railway stations and
around other growing cities specifically
to allow the under 40s to be able to own
their own homes do you still want to
build a million homes on Greenbelt and
the like so what I don't want to do K is
build it on the green belt because I do
think well I've changed I've changed my
view on that I'm still very keen for the
under 40s to be able to own their own
homes but what I've seen is that the way
these top-down targets have resulted in
having the opposite effect of getting
the homes built and I'm now of the view
that what we need to do is have
incentives to get local councils to set
up investment zones and do things
differently because the current system
isn't working okay so you've changed
your mind on that one uh Jill from
Tunbridge Wells are you angry Jill just
available
hi hi Liz hi how important is it to
balance the books
so the answer is it is important over
the long term to make sure that the
private sector is growing faster than
the public sector and we are able to
generate the revenues for our economy
and also be able to pay for our public
services but it isn't right to try and
balance the book straight away when
we've had a major Global crisis like
covid and every single country in the
world has built up debts from that
crisis and in fact we have lower levels
of debt than most of the G7 countries so
I think trying to balance the books
prematurely is actually
counterproductive because if you put up
taxes and you stop businesses forming
you stop new investment and you stop
economic growth you're less likely to be
able to pay down the debt over the
longer term
happy with that no it doesn't look as
though so what's your follow-up question
on that one Liz I do not want to see my
children and my grandchildren incumbered
with huge debt at a time of rising
interest rates Bank of England today and
at a time of high inflation the one
thing Margaret Thatcher believed in was
sound money this is not sound economics
and the whole business about economic
growth tax cuts do not necessarily
produce economic growth if you look at
Germany for example it has much higher
corporation tax than we have and indeed
even with the Rises that are in the
pipeline and yet their economy is not
tanking in the way that ours is tanking
so I think this is this question of
balancing the books is really
fundamental signed by Source sound
economics well we we have lower levels
of debt than countries like the US
Canada and Japan so it's simply not true
to say that we have particularly High
national debt at the moment but what I
do know is that families across the
country are struggling to pay their
bills and what I would do is sent
interest rates Liz I remember those days
I had to pay a mortgage of 15 are we
going back to that level again no
because we've got an independent bank of
England to make decisions about interest
rates and we're that we're we're nowhere
near that that position at at all but to
say that we're going to put up taxes to
the highest level and Beyond the highest
level in 70 years and we think there'll
be no consequences for economic growth
I'm afraid I think that's wrong and I
speak to lots of companies lots of
businesses who are very concerned about
the proposals to raise corporation tax
they're very concerned about the level
of interest rates they're very concerned
about the regulations on their
businesses at the moment the fact is
that Britain has got less competitive
relative to other countries under these
corporation tax proposals we would have
corporation tax that is 10 points higher
than Ireland yeah and it will make us
less competitive Germany and you don't
get Germany or Germany has a very very
different economic system from the UK
okay we've got one time for one more
question Tom from gateshead where's the
charm we'll come back to other questions
Tom hi sorry hi thanks very much Liz why
did you announce a well-researched and
fully costed policy in which you openly
said you valued the work of teachers
nurses and police officers in Newcastle
where I work less than you value those
in Guildford for example
we're having this election because of
poor judgment and Trust
why should we trust your judgment
well the reason that I immediately
decided not to pursue that policy is it
was being misinterpreted in fact in
exactly the way you said because it
wasn't about teachers or nurses or
doctors and immediately as there were
concerns expressed about this policy I
said we're not going ahead with it and I
do think in politics there are times
when you have to make judgments about
what is right and you have to be honest
with the public and I was very honest
about the situation it wasn't a core
part of my policy plan but I'd rather be
up front and if there's a problem make a
decision and deal it with it straight
away and I think you can see in my time
as foreign secretary in my time as trade
secretary I've been completely upfront
about everything I've done I've
explained why I've done it I've
explained when there is a change why
there is a change and that's the
approach I would take as prime minister
so the press release didn't say that it
said that it would be um it in order to
reach the 8.8 billion in savings that it
would be expanded out Beyond Civil
Service uh be beyond the Civil Service
itself
um so that's a mistake WIll you
apologize because it was actually quite
offensive
well I have been very clear
that I will not go ahead with this
policy and that I have made a decision
to do that straight away and I've been
upfront about that I don't think there
is anything to be ashamed of of saying
publicly that this is not working as I
wanted it to work and therefore I have
changed the position on it and I'm not
going ahead with it okay this gentleman
had a view on that just wait for your
microphone so can we just get a
microphone down here thank you you were
shaking your head sir I did yeah I hate
this um
apologize you know for everything that
you might have said I just don't really
don't understand it the the opposition
rule was asking uh other politicians to
apologize for what they may or may not
have done uh and it really doesn't sit
well with me when somebody's asking for
your vote you don't expect to be
offended
well
simple as that what's that supposed to
mean but you know
holidays
we are going into very very difficult
times as a country yeah and we've just
talked about that and we need somebody
leading this country who is prepared to
make decisions who is prepared to deal
with issues as they arise okay and is
prepared to be upfront with the public
okay and I think I've demonstrated that
in everything I've done in all of the
jobs I've held okay during this campaign
okay I'll come back to you imagine if I
may if you take a seat please mistrust
it's time for my go everybody here we
are glass of water I wanted to pick up
actually uh just where we'd left off
there on on what the gentleman was
asking you
um about on this press release we do
want I just want to bottom it out so we
know exactly where we are
um
you said
that public sector pay policy has been
misrepresented by the media here's the
proposals that you released introduce
Regional pay boards tailoring pay to the
cost of living where civil servants
actually work saving up to 8.8 billion
pounds per year so how have we
misrepresented you so far well what what
I am clear about is that policy was not
about teachers and doctors but can I be
clear Kay that I'm not going ahead with
this because you said you were because
presented I'm just clarified because
because of the concerns that have been
expressed okay and when something is
just clarified when there's an issue
okay I deal with it okay but just to
clarify whether you're misrepresented or
not you highlighted a very specific
saving 8.8 billion pounds how did you
reach that figure well I don't have the
details and I do think discussing a
policy that I'm not well I can tell you
obviously these people it's it's very
pressing for these people and certainly
it's some of them so we just want to
bottom it out and then we're definitely
there and I'm sure you won't have to
answer these questions again it's
exactly the same figure the 8.8 billion
that was issued by the taxpayers uh
Alliance they say Regional based pay
could allow private sector salaries to
catch up with the public sector this can
be done by freezing or reducing pay for
existing roles and new positions in
other words pick up for nurses doctors
firemen police officers in less affluent
areas which is what this gentleman was
saying that wasn't what you were
proposing you've changed absolutely that
was not my intention but given the
concern that was caused I took an
immediate decision not to proceed with
this policy okay I am somebody who
immediately if there are issues of
concern and those are not delivering
what I want to deliver I will make a
decision to do the right thing and
that's what I've done not just this
gentleman here but Ben houch and the
conservative mayor of Tears Valley said
there's no way you can do this without a
massive pay cut for five and a half
million people including nurses police
officers and our Armed Forces outside of
London
do you accept
that you made a mistake by announcing
the policy I do accept that the way the
policy has been interpreted to cover
those people was not right and that's
why I took an immediate decision not to
go ahead with it you offended people
though you misread the mood you accepted
it was a mistake what I've said is I
absolutely accept that it wasn't the
right policy to deal with this situation
and therefore I withdrew the policy
immediately and I'm somebody who is
honest and upfront okay I dealt with the
issue immediately after the concerns
were expressed about the how this policy
had been interpreted and I've dealt with
it straight away okay it was a mistake
though well as I've said I've withdrawn
the policy we're not going ahead with
the policy so therefore you know the the
points you're making are about a policy
that isn't happening no no what I'm
saying is should good leaders own their
mistakes
um or should they blame others I'm not
blaming you blame anybody else I'm not
I'm not I'm saying that um the policy
has been misrepresented by various
people but what I don't want at this
time when people are struggling with the
cost of living is to concern people with
this policy which isn't a core part of
my policy platform and I'm not going
ahead with it okay let's talk about the
economy scene as we've moved on to that
I want to talk to you about your plans
to help the worst off if I may we've
spoken to Selena she's a single mom in
the northeast of England she works
part-time to support her three children
and earns just over ten thousand pounds
a year
what will you do to help her when her
energy bills reach 500 pounds a month in
January so first of all I'll take a
media action to reverse the National
Insurance rise
won't help her she earns less than 12
570 pounds so she would she works also
the green energy Levy will be taking
that's 150 pounds and her bit and so
that's a drop in the bucket really isn't
it and what I really like nine days of
energy for her and what I will also do
is work to increase the amount of
supplies we're getting out of the North
Sea so that we can get more gas into our
system so we can move forward on dealing
with the energy crisis and energy
security because ultimately ultimately
these problems can only be dealt with by
first of all making sure Putin is
defeated by the ukrainians so that we
don't have this energy supply problem
and also by releasing more reserves in
the North Sea I'm also in favor of
fracking in areas that support it so we
get more more of our domestic energy
Supply but what I can assure UK is I
will do all I can to help people who are
struggling with the cost of living I
understand that people are going through
difficult times and if there are any
more available resources of course I
would put that to helping people with
the cost of living
okay these are Selena's words I'm really
worried about how I'm going to keep my
children warm and fed this is going to
cost lives if they don't do something
now
but this is so why it's so very
important that we offer
support to businesses that we it's not
going to help her well it will help her
because
the real danger we're in as a country
and this is what the bank of England has
said today is we're facing a recession
and what a recession would mean is
people losing their jobs businesses
going out of business people struggling
across the country so that's why it's so
important we do things like keeping
corporation tax slow keeping personal
taxes as low as possible getting getting
things like infrastructure structure
projects done quicker to grow the
economy that is ultimately the way we
are going to deal with this crisis is
through economic growth okay here's an
idea what about the windfall tax shell
posted profits of 9.3 billion pounds
between April and June if we put that
another way shell made
1190 pounds per second so since I
started this sentence they've made 17
000 pounds in profit why don't we have
another win full tax well the problem
with a windfall tax is that it might
secure money in the short term but what
it does is it puts off companies
investing in Britain in the long term
because they said they wouldn't they
think at any point
they could be taxed and I think that is
a problem what we need to show is
Britain's open for business we're a
country that keeps to our word of what
our taxes are and windfall taxes are
essentially surprise taxes that
companies don't know that are happening
what I would do instead Kay is make sure
we're incentivizing the likes of shell
to be
releasing more resources from the North
Sea to actually help the problem that we
face which is a lack of energy Supply
they had a BP said that he would
continue to his business would continue
to invest if there was another in full
time
it's not just BP though it's the signal
that it sends to every business across
the country so the government is willing
to give you a surprise tax and I think
that is a problem for Britain I've
already talked about how our corporation
tax rate is uncompetitive compared to
other countries if we also have a
reputation for levying a surprise tax on
any industry that makes a profit that is
a big problem for our country shell is
giving their um shareholders 6.5 billion
pounds
people at home watching who can't afford
to heat their homes uh come the winter
will be horrified at that look at who
these shareholders are these
shareholders are often people with
pensions you know Pension funds you know
shareholders are not you know all sort
of men in seat sitting sitting in
offices you know there is a real there's
no such thing as free money and I just
think we've got to be very careful if
the UK gets a reputation for arbitrarily
taking money in tax so we've not sort of
done through the official tax system I
think that's a problem okay let's move
on to Foreign Affairs we've talked about
it a little bit do you want a sip of
water you're very welcome
um talking about Taiwan I'm sure that
we've all seen haven't we what's been
happening in Taiwan over the last few
days
um as foreign secretary you told a
select committee last month that we
should have armed Ukraine earlier should
we arm Taiwan no
what we do need to make sure is that
democracies like Taiwan are defended and
yesterday I put out a statement with my
fellow G7 foreign ministers about the
very difficult situation in Taiwan and
concern about the rhetoric that we're
hearing from China the escalatory
rhetoric of course we have a very a very
secure control system for exports in the
United Kingdom and we do license exports
to Taiwan at the moment exports that are
provided by the private sector so should
we earn them or not well what I'm saying
is we already license equipment to go to
Taiwan okay and it's a long-standing
policy of the UK government to do that
okay you said to the Foreign Affairs
Select Committee in June a month before
last we should have done things earlier
we should have been supplying the
defensive weapons into Ukraine earlier
we need to learn that that lesson for
Taiwan every piece of equipment we have
sent takes months of a training so the
sooner here we do that the better so
just to clarify we do license arms that
go there but that that is as far as
we're going to go at this stage
yes
that is as far as we will go at this
stage but we are working with our allies
very closely on this because there are
countries like the United States Japan
okay who also are extremely concerned
about the future of Taiwan okay and what
we need to do is work collectively and I
have championed the G7 acting together
as an economic NATO to challenge some of
China's economic coercion practices but
also to make sure we're looking at the
security situation and making sure
democracies like Taiwan are predicted
I'm sure you can understand Kay that I
can't go into every detail of those
conversations because on TV but it's a
it's a very important principle that we
do not allow aggressors to
to evade Democratic Democratic places
we've seen Nancy Pelosi another strong
influential woman in Taiwan this week
will you visit Taiwan if you're prime
minister
uh we we currently have a long-standing
yes
we we have a long-standing position look
at the foreign secretary the ministry of
defense and the Prime Minister okay
visit let me talk to you about uh
Ukraine was it an area of judgment to
say you'd support Brits going to fight
in Ukraine what I was very clear about
is that I supported the cause of the
fight in Ukraine but I've always been
clear that the travel advices that
British people should not go to Ukraine
no what you said was I do support that
when zelensky called for international
volunteers ukrainians are fighting for
Freedom not just for Ukraine but the
whole of Europe and you did support
people you did support Brits going to
Ukraine to fight well what I support
what are your own defenses what I was
saying is that I supported the cause in
Ukraine okay your foreign office website
said Brit's traveling to fight in
Ukraine could be committing an act of
terrorism did you know that when you
said it
well what what I've said is that I
support the cause in Ukraine and
actually I've done a lot of work to
support British citizens who have been
detained in Ukraine who've been there in
the long term and the foreign office has
provided those people are you sorry that
people misinterpreted what you were
saying
well what I have said is that the defend
the advice was very clear the travel
advice was very clear and I announced
that publicly that people shouldn't go
to Ukraine but I think what is happening
here because what is happening Poland
who were going into Ukraine who were
Brits that had crossed the border and
were then subsequently going into
Ukraine well many you know there have
been many British people going into
Ukraine okay during the war but we are
very clear about our travel advice okay
I've got some quick fire questions for
you if I may here we go in your first
meeting with the queen will you
apologize for wanting to abolish the
monarchy well I've already
I've already met the queen and she's
been far too polite to raise that issue
with me and I will not be uh I will not
be raising it with her okay but if she
did would you apologize
well I was wrong uh I was wrong to say
what I did at the time okay will you be
apologizing to the first minister of
Scotland when you see her
no I won't
uh what's the naughtiest thing you've
ever done I'm sorry
certainly TV oh was it that naughty well
my daughters are watching so I don't
know
prime minister
it's the most invasive exposed period in
any politician's life is there anything
that you feel that you would want to
come clean with the audience here in the
studio and at home because there's no
one else listening so it's all fine I
can just tell anything that you need to
get off your chest
there were I can tell you okay there are
no skeletons in my closet I think
everything I've ever said and done is
known about very publicly would you
remove the whip from Boris Johnson of
Eastbound to have deliberately misled
Parliament over partygate
um I'm not making any pre-judgments
about that why not well I'm just I'm not
making pre-judgments I'll see what the
committee says but if they say
deliberately misled Parliament as I said
I'm I'm not making any pre-judgments
about okay what one change by the way
I'm very clear he didn't mislead
Parliament well we'll see what the uh
business uh what the committee says what
one change to the system would you make
to restore Integrity because there's a
lot of people here in the studio
thank you
uh not just here in the studio but
watching at home as well you know
Integrity has been lost in the
Westminster bubble what would you do to
change it well I think the the answer to
restoring Integrity isn't introducing
more rules because we have endless rules
and codes the issue is about Clarity and
Leadership and doing what you say you
will do and following through on your
promises what I would also do as prime
minister is restore the chief whip to
number 12 Downing Street the chief whip
was moved out by Aleister Campbell and
replaced with the Press office I think
that was a mistake because it reduced
the link between the Prime Minister the
chief Whip and the Parliamentary party
and I would make sure I I would make
sure we had zero tolerance for bad
behavior in the Parliamentary party but
we're also supporting MPS because as you
say you know being prime minister is an
exposed job but actually being an MP at
the moment is pretty difficult you
there's all kinds of difficult things
said about you on social media it can be
very difficult for people's family lives
so at the same time as making sure we
have discipline and you know making sure
people are honest and behave themselves
we also do need to offer MPS that
welfare advisor
and you stand by if you would a new
ethics advisor
well I will I will look at the role of
the ethics advisor but
I'm somebody who
does act with integrity and I think
people have seen that in every job I've
done and I slightly worry about
Outsourcing ethics to somebody else uh
so as prime minister I should never
charge the difference between right and
wrong and of course there need to be
proper independent complaints procedure
there needs to be proper whistleblowing
procedures but I would want to look at
how how those things are structured okay
you were loyal to the PM despite parties
during lockdown
or when he promoted a man who groped
colleagues or when he was rewriting the
rules to help out his mates
um throughout that you stood shoulder to
shoulder with a man who has betrayed the
Office of Prime Minister I don't agree
with that characterization okay I
supported I supported Boris Johnson for
the leadership I think he did a good job
as our prime minister he delivered
brexit he delivered the vaccines he also
did a fantastic job of leading the Free
World in standing up to Vladimir Putin
in Ukraine yes he made mistakes that's
absolutely true you know he he said
sorry for the mistakes he made but I
think it's completely wrong to
characterize him in that way
I don't know what does the audience
think we're here yeah a great a great a
grade no no no
Okay so I think it's opinion opinion is
divided on that issue I think we can
hear we can hear from from people in the
audience but I have worked closely with
Boris Johnson I know the difficult times
he went to you know he was in very
serious trouble uh when he had covered
and you know it's been a very very
difficult time to be in government but
look you know many mistakes were made
during lockdown okay
um you know by by many people and I just
think to sort of say that
this was the you know crowning problem
is it is not right yeah some in charge
of policy some not a final question for
you just before we let you go you were a
remainer and now you're not you
supported uh Brits to fight in Ukraine
then you didn't you wanted to build on
the Green Belt no you don't you wanted
to abolish the monarchy and now you
don't you wanted to arm Taiwan and now
I'm not sure if you're saying whether
you do or not you wanted several things
so we do provide them with those you
wanted to cut civil servants pay in the
regions and then you said you didn't
will the real Liz trust please stand up
who you know I didn't come from a
traditional conservative background my
first political experience was going on
a CND march with my mother age seven you
know I then uh as a teenager joined the
liberal Democrats I'm not sure how much
I should be held to account for things I
said when I was 18 or 19. but I've
always had a belief that we can be a
more successful country that people
should be able to control their own
lives I've always believed in the
principle of Freedom I've always
believed in low taxation yes my views on
other issues have developed over time
but show me somebody who has the same
views at 19 and 49 and I'll show you
somebody who's not capable of original
thoughts so yes you know I have I have
you know developed My Views I've
considered things differently and I also
listen to people okay and I think that's
important so what we've been talking
about today
literally the same amount of time I did
say well the real this trust please
stand up you're still sitting down
try to get rid of me at least
thank you
let's get some reaction from the
audience should we gentlemen over here I
heard um who was shouting out gentlemen
here yep boom there sir go on
I was going to say and Liz mentioned
about nothing in her closet she'd
mentioned about integrity does that mean
at some point in the future she's proved
to have lied about something she's going
to resign I don't know what do you think
that's what I wanted to ask her who else
has got a question the lady here had her
hand up earlier yes Madam um I was just
wanting to ask if she actually believed
that Boris Johnson's actions had damaged
the conservative party and their chances
in the next general election okay great
question have you you obviously all
mostly are in fact all of you are going
to be people that will be voting for our
next prime minister have you received
your ballot papers yet no you still
haven't received them you have one
person but most people haven't okay well
obviously we're moving on to the next
section now of our program you'll be
able to hear what Mr sunak thinks and
then we're going to ask you what you
think how does that sound ladies and
gentlemen wish you sooner
so we're going to do exactly the same as
we did with list trust is that okay
we're gonna start with the questions
from the audience and then I've got some
questions for you as well if that's okay
all right here we go let's start our
first question uh with Matthew Matthew
from Kent there he is in the middle
there Matthew
is there a point that you would stand
aside in this campaign Mr sunac given
opinion polls appointing to a a dominant
mistrust win and also we're seeing daily
declarations from Big Tory big guns uh
in her favor
well thanks for the question Matthew and
the quick answer is no and that's
because well thank you
and you know what that's that's because
I'm fighting for something I really
believe in and I'm taking my ideas
around the country I'm talking to all of
you our members across the country about
what I think is best for our country at
a really difficult time and I want to
have that debate with people because I
passionately believe what I'm saying is
right I want to convince as many people
of that as possible and hopefully I can
do that with you all tonight but you
talk about big guns I mean I've also had
in the MP phase of this in Parliament
the most number of MPS support me not
just in the first round but in every
round since you talk about big guns
coming out I just had Nigel Lawson this
morning Margaret Thatcher's Chancellor
supporting my approach to the economy
Michael Howard a former leader of our
party just introduced me at a hustings
yesterday William Hague another leader
of our party my predecessor in Richmond
and North Yorkshire all supporting my
candidacy so look I think I've got lots
of support that I'm going to fight
incredibly hard till the last day of
this campaign for each and every one of
your votes the stakes are really high
I'm passionate what I believe in and I
want to try and convince you all that
I'm right anybody else that's going to
I'll get a few you're all very quiet
though so you've got a question uh hi um
now I've been a Tory for last 30 years
and I did stand for parliament in 2005.
now I've been absolutely disgusted with
the level of disunity within the Tory
party so yes I will be supporting you uh
but once you if you do become Prime
Minister how will you ensure that you
unite the Tory party so that we can win
the next general election yeah no I'm so
glad you are so it's a really important
point because I think I think how we
select this audience we're all on the
same team right we're all part of the
same conservative family and we are
going to need to come back together
afterwards and look I think you can take
some comfort from the fact that not only
do I have the most support of MPS in
Parliament that support is drawn from
every bit of our parliamentary party
people in the north MPS in the South MPS
have voted remain MPS who voted leave
experienced colleagues the likes of
which we just talked about in Matthew's
question but brand new MPS as well MPS
in rural areas and urban areas so that's
the breadth of my support because that's
the kind of person I am that I can build
a broad team around me and that's what
I'm going to do in government I want to
make sure that we have a government that
represents all the talents and
traditions of our amazing party and you
saw some of that on display in this
leadership election early on I want all
of you to be able to look at the
government and feel a piece of your view
of conservatism represented that's how
we're going to bring people back
together because we all know in this
room the enemy is not me or Liz or
anyone else our real opposition is kirst
armor in the labor party and I'm the
person who can take the fight to them
and win the next election for all of us
because that's what we all want to see
isn't it
um
actually that's a similar question to
Andrew from West London where's Andrew
Andrew I'm over here you're over there
as well Andrew were you happy with that
response well
sort of but yeah I think
I think historically we have to look at
the fact that parties that are divided
do not win elections we are two years
out less than two years out from a
general election
what specifics can we do what specifics
can you do
to reunite the party
well well Andrew you're right we are
only a couple of years out from a
general election and that's why getting
on with the job as quickly as possible
is really important we don't have time
to waste so it starts day one with
building that team that I talked about
that does bring people back together
around the cabinet table and across
government no more factions no more who
supported who in the leadership contest
we have to put all that aside the moment
this contests end and start looking
forward and start delivering for the
British people we've got real challenges
and I'm sure we're going to get to talk
about the economy in a minute but that's
the number one challenge we've got to
get the NHS backlogs down we've got to
get to grips with illegal migration
we've got to make sure that we provide
more energy for us all at home there's
lots of challenges we've got and we need
to get on and do them fast so if we've
got a brand new team United in purpose
to deliver for the British people and
focus on the prize of winning the next
election I think that will Galvanize
mines I'm the person that can bring
people together and lead us to that
Vision so okay can I come back very
quickly if you wouldn't mind so so how
many people in the current cabinet would
you have in your cabinet okay well well
Andrew I wouldn't I don't think you'd
expect me to answer that a it's
premature as we heard from the first
question I've got a lot of work to do in
this campaign and I'm going to fight for
every vote and that's what I'm focused
on right now but I will tell you I will
build a team that reflects the talents
and traditions of our entire party okay
and that's what you will be able to look
up at my government okay and see
yourself and everyone else reflecting
okay Claire from solihull okay hi there
so the my question is the hi uh the
security of this country worries me
greatly with all this cyber rattling
from Russia China Iran and North Korea
so if you become PM will you commit to
increasing the size and budget of our
Armed Forces to make this country once
again a force to be reckoned with
yes Claire that the simple answer is
absolutely and I don't want to say once
again because I think we are already a
force to be reckoned with we're an
amazing country that projects our values
and our influence around the world
supporting our allies so I don't think
we have to think that we're not we
already are but there's always more we
can do now remember I was the chancellor
who oversaw the largest increase in the
defense budget since the end of the Cold
War that's my track record and actually
I singled out the ministry of Defense in
the middle of the pandemic for a special
treatment because they were going
through a period where they were looking
at Future threats they needed the
certainty of knowing that they had the
funding to make all those Investments
and the new technologies that will keep
us safe that's why I gave them the
special treatment that's not what the
Prime Minister said he said that you had
to be actually Ben Wallace said the
Prime Minister had to overrule you no
that's not right we actually do awesome
I'm not going to talk ill of any of my
colleagues But ultimately I'm the
chancellor that's responsible for the
decisions on how we spend our money and
that's what I did right but you don't
have to take my my word for it there
when it came to Ukraine what else did we
do I managed to find two billion pounds
from across government to send to
Ukraine to support them so we can help
them and protect our values and stand up
to Russian aggression but what I'm not
going to do is stand here and give you
an arbitrary Target and I know that's
what Liz has said in this campaign and I
don't believe in that I don't think
that's the right response to defense
spending I don't believe in arbitrary
targets I believe in taking a
threat-based approach I believe in
looking at the threats we face and then
allocating spending accordingly so what
I can commit to you Claire is this I
will tell you I will invest whatever it
takes to keep you and everyone else in
our country safe because that is the
first duty of a prime minister and it's
certainly the first duty of a
conservative prime minister follow-up
from this lady here just wait for the
microphone Madame if you would there we
go thank you you're also the chancellor
that introduced eat out to dial out at a
cost of 850 million pounds and according
to the University of Warwick that was
responsible for an increase of new
covert cases of between 8 and 17 sent
well actually that's one study that said
that and I don't think it's right and it
doesn't explain the fact that in almost
any every other country around Europe
everyone else experienced another wave
of covid and they didn't all have the
same policy so it's a bit odd to blame
that policy for an increase in covert
cases when that happened across Europe
and indeed across most of the world but
I'll tell you what I was thinking at
that moment what I was looking at was a
situation where we had hundreds of
thousands of largely small Hospitality
businesses that were on the brink of
bankruptcy because in this country
everyone was so scared and all the
evidence said that no one was going to
go back out again and an economy like
ours that would have been disastrous and
you know what's worse two million people
work in all those small businesses and
those two million people are
disproportionately young
they're women they're working part-time
they're people who are coming off
unemployment benefit into work so as a
matter of social justice I wanted to
protect those jobs okay those families
livelihoods that's why I did it and
everywhere I go in this campaign across
the country I have people who come up to
me and say thank you for that because it
saved our business and it saved those
jobs Tom
they're like that one Mr Tom from Berry
St Edmunds I'm right behind you okay
there we go I'm always behind everything
I'm sorry I'm a town councilor for bury
since Edmonds oh brilliant thank you and
we lost our Kings Road NHS dentist they
were brilliant that was in 2018. now
some of us are going around talking like
tube stations mind the gap mind the gap
what can be done it's 2022 we need and
it's just industry because frankly a lot
of us cannot afford to go private and we
have fantastic private dentists but we
need our NHS back what can you do how
soon can you do it that's the problem
I'm running out of teeth
I have seven fillings and and that's
because I drank an enormous amount of
coke when I was a Youngster so I know I
feel your pain and we do need good
dentistry and look the NHS first of all
is everyone's number one Public Service
priority and I grew up in an NHS
household you may have heard on this
campaign my dad
just checking you never know right you
know my mom ran a chemist where I grew
up so I spent my time working in that I
understand how important especially
Primary Care is but look you know if
we're going to get to grips with this
and make sure that there is money for
NHS Dentistry we just have to be bolder
about reforming the NHS to get more
efficiency out of it now I'm someone who
you can absolutely trust with the NHS
I'm someone who did something quite
difficult and that's create a new
funding stream to support not just the
NHS but social care because it does
start with putting more resources in to
help recover from the pandemic was an
easy thing for me to do lots of people
are upset with me about it but I believe
it was the right thing for the country
the right thing to support our fantastic
NHS doctors and nurses but money's not
enough we need to reform things so we
can get more efficiency and invest in
things like Dentistry I'll give you one
example of something that I'm prepared
to do which is a bit bold it is a bit
radical and not everyone will love it
but I want to show you that I'm going to
bring some change and that's tackling
missed appointments now we have over 10
million missed appointments every year
and it's not just GPS it's in hospitals
at the same time we've got lots of
people sitting there anxiously waiting
for treatment and I've said that's not
acceptable so we need to be tougher on
missed appointments because if we are
then if people can cancel them in
advance properly we free up all that
extra capacity and none of us have had
to pay an extra penny in taxes to do
that how is that workable though thank
you how's that how's
people who can't afford to pay the 10
pounds and they miss the so they can't
pay to afford to pay their fine
um do they not get treatment in future
what happens well actually okay as I
said it you don't have to do it People's
First Mist it can be for people who
missed a second appointment because
there are just so many that there's a
lot of space in the system and I do
think it's right to actually say hang on
we believe in an NHS that's free at the
point of views but it's not free at the
point of misuse and when people don't
show up for appointments they are
depriving other people of treatment that
they need so there's someone equally
vulnerable waiting there sitting on a
waiting list waiting to see their
consultant or their GP and they're not
getting that chance because someone else
has just not bothered to show up and
that's not all right and look there will
be some people like you who say oh gosh
maybe we shouldn't do that but if we're
not
but at the end of the day if we all want
to cut taxes in this country if we want
to find money to spend more on Dentistry
we have to be prepared to do things
differently challenge the system and
that's what I'm prepared to do because I
want to have great health care I want to
have great Dentistry for you and for my
future fillings but I do want to be able
to cut your taxes too we're only gonna
be able to do that if we're going to
reform things and do things differently
that's the kind of prime minister I'm
going to be we can only be compassionate
once
um Jeff from Devon Jeff where are we
jack hey Jack oh you're all over here
today is it Jeff was it yes sir hi hi
um given the problems we've had with
borders control and obviously the
massive controversy with the Rwanda
policy what's your plan to
um cut illegal Channel Crossings yes
great question and something I've been
talking a lot about over the last couple
of weeks look you know I'm the product
of this country's extraordinarily
compassionate approach to welcoming
immigrants to our Shores my family a
beneficiary of that probably others in
the audience and it's something that we
should all feel really proud of it's
something that Britain is amazing at and
even most recently Ukraine Hong Kong
Syria Afghanistan we showed our
compassion but it is also absolutely
right that we have control over our
borders because all the people I just
mentioned came here legally and what is
not right is for people to break the
rules and come here illegally this
scenes we see on our TV screens in Small
Boat Crossings are wrong and they need
to stop and I'm prepared again to do
some different things to be bold and
radical to stop them there's a 10-point
plan on my website with a video so you
please go and have a look at that
tonight and anyone else that's
interested in this topic I'll give you
two examples of things I'm prepared to
do now one is we need to change the
definition of asylum and move away from
this European definition which has
become very broad it's exploited by
Lefty lawyers and means it's very hard
to remove people I suggest moving to a
different definition another legal
standard internationally used by I think
the Australians and others and that is a
much tighter definition and will allow
us to reject more people so that's one
thing we can do the second thing is
we've got to get smarter about our
foreign policy at the moment we'll
happily talk to a country and talk about
the trade deal we're going to give them
and maybe even the aid that we're going
to send that country but we don't then
also say hang on you have to take back
your failed Asylum Seekers well that's
not right we should be more joined up we
should be tougher about that so that's
just two other things in my 10 point
plan but fundamentally we must get a
grip of this we have to make the Rwanda
policy work I will do whatever it takes
including legal changes if required to
make it work so we get control of our
borders although we're a compassionate
country and we'll always be it's
entirely right and many of us vote to
brexit for this reason that we are in
control of who's coming here that's a
simple thing and I will deliver it as PM
okay
Applause on that one gentle them there
really quickly because we need to move
on if we can just stretch over with the
microphone for you sir there we go your
question really quickly so we currently
have a point-based immigration system
do you propose any changes or are you
happy to keep it as is this
silicon on immigration look for we have
to tackle this question of illegal but
just question on a legal migration we
should tackle that robustly and
radically so that's part one now with
the rest of immigration right there's a
couple of things I I want to be
pragmatic about this so I want to make
sure that we're also supporting our
economy to grow and that means having an
immigration system that actually
welcomes the best and the brightest from
around the world because if we want to
grow our economy if we want people here
who are going to set up companies of the
future who are going to come and
research in our universities who are
going to come and work at some of our
fastest growing companies actually we
want to have a Visa regime that makes
with us the best place in the world for
all those people to come I started
reforming the system as Chancellor and
as prime minister I want to finish the
job so that the best and the brightest
wherever they are around the world
America India Brazil wherever they think
huh the UK is the place I want to come
because we're going to track them here
it's going to be good for all of us it's
going to be good for the economy and
that's something that I want to deliver
okay we've got a question from Alexander
I'm trust Alexander you've got a
question
hi Alexander yeah good to see you buddy
uh what does honesty mean to you in
politics and Leadership
great question so it honestly in a sense
it means telling you the truth right and
even when that's not easy and I think
you can see in this leadership election
that's what I'm doing right and that
first question at the beginning of how
I'm doing in the polls and all of that
right I am saying some things that are
maybe not the easiest thing in the world
to hear I'm not sitting here or standing
here promising you tens and tens of
billions of pounds of goodies straight
away because I don't think that's the
right thing to do for our economy I
think it's risky I think it risks making
the inflation problem far worse and
costing you all far more and you know
what my life would be far easier if I
wasn't saying that right but I want to
be honest with you I want to be straight
with a country about the challenges we
face and what is going to be required to
fix them and that's why I think you can
trust me on this because I'm prepared to
do that even though it's going to cost
me politically at two Mr sunak though
at two Mr sunac we've seen the images of
what you were allegedly uh the the uh
Nadine Doris I think it was who came up
with this I don't know has anybody seen
it standby stabbing you in the back I
mean how do you respond to that sorry
okay what are you but my point is we're
talking about trust you can't be trusted
um
interest that's there you go right
perfect right okay let's let's address
that that's actually great that you've
raised it sorry what was your name sir
Stephen right so yes I worked with the
Prime Minister for a couple of years and
I'm really proud of the work we achieved
together actually and I think he
deserves enormous credit for what he
achieved during that time and I as I
said I'm proud to have been a part of it
and he gave me the job I had and I'm
grateful to him for it but it got to a
point where it was too difficult for me
to stay now I we had well documented
differences of opinion on economic
policy as you can see in this leadership
campaign by the way and it's simply
impossible for a Chancellor and prime
minister not to be on the same page when
it comes to economic policy that doesn't
make sense and and there's no way that
can work so of course I had no choice
but to go but also it came to a point
where the government was on the wrong
side of an ethical problem that I could
not defend
and enough was enough for me but it
wasn't just me it was 60 other members
of parliament all left the government at
the same time because for them enough
was enough and that's why we're here
because we need to change things in
December last year did they Rishi you've
been campaigning for a long time and it
was perfectly timed a cynical motivation
to try and get you into number 10. no
that's just simply not true so I was due
to give a speech with the Prime Minister
the next week and in the conversations
about putting that speech together on
the economy it was clear our differences
were too big to reconcile okay so that
was the reason plus I think let's not
look at the hit the bus with rose-tinted
spectacles here everyone remembers what
was going on with Chris pincher right
that that was a serious ethical question
that the government was on the wrong
side of again and I couldn't defend it
maybe you're okay to defend that I
wasn't okay to defend it 60 other
members of the government were not okay
to defend it because it was wrong and
that's why we're here because we need to
change things we need to bring trust and
integrity and decency and honesty back
into politics and that's what I want to
do as prime minister okay okay I'm gonna
have to brush up on my Shakespearean
references I can tell
um let's bring in David from London
finally where are you David David's here
hi daily gongs hi Kate thank you David
hi good evening Mr Scenic
um how are you balance the need to
address the escalating cost of living
crisis
particularly for those that are on Lower
incomes alongside the need to keep the
economy in good order and national debt
not spiraling out of control you know
David you know your question is actually
the most important one facing the
country right now right and I'm sure
many of you saw what the bank and Bank
of England had to say today
and if we in the conservative party need
to get real and fast because the lights
on the economy are flashing red and the
root cause is inflation now I'm worried
that Liz truss's plans will make the
situation worse and what I want to do is
different I think the government's
number one priority should be grappling
with inflation that's what I want to do
I also want to help people with a cost
of living over the Autumn winter
particularly as you said the people who
most need our help and that's what I
announced as Chancellor that's how I
acted over the past two years that's
what I'll do as your prime minister
that's what conservative government
should do support those who need our
help most at a time of need but then
also I want to grow the economy and I
want businesses to be producing more and
that's how we're going to not just grow
the economy and create jobs is how we're
going to get inflation down over time
I've got a plan to do all of those
things but it all starts with not making
the situation worse because if we just
put fuel on the fire of this inflation
spiral all of us all of you are going to
just end up with higher mortgage rates
savings and pensions that are eaten away
and misery for Millions I don't want
that to happen and that's why I am so
focused on gripping inflation first okay
ladies and gentlemen Mr sunac have a
second
yes why not right excellent
right my turn here we go let's talk
about the economy to start with should
we today as that was being pointed out
the bank of England uh saying that we're
going to be in recession before the end
of the year and that's going to last
until 2024.
uh people watching at home and I'm
guessing some people here as well facing
months and months of hardship you've
been their Chancellor for the last two
years why on Earth should they trust you
with accusing number 10.
in fact because they've seen me as
Chancellor over the last couple of years
and I think actually okay probably the
first time people really saw me was that
first press conference when there was an
enormous amount of anxiety in the
country about what was going to happen
to people's jobs their livelihoods their
businesses and they didn't really know
who I was I'd just been a maid
Chancellor a couple of weeks before but
I stepped up at that moment to act
boldly and radically to design things
that had never been done before in this
country like furlough that ended up
protecting over 10 million jobs saved
over a million businesses help families
get through what are two very difficult
years and for our economy to emerge at
the end of that in Far More resilient
shape than anyone had anticipated at the
beginning and when I go around the
country people know that that's what I
did for them they're grateful for it and
that's what I want to do as prime
minister because right now we Face
similarly large economic challenges and
it's particularly because experience
that I'm well placed to deal with
nothing you can do about recession
though is there or is there
of course there is of course there is
back to David David's question you know
the number one thing we have to do is
not make the situation worse what is
causing the recession right as you heard
from the bank of England today and I
think Liz said something before which
I'm just going to correct it's not the
tax burden that is causing the recession
that's simply wrong what's causing a
recession is inflation like that's the
root of the problems we have not just
here but in America and elsewhere so the
way we're going to get through this
first and foremost is gripping inflation
now we will and I always have stood by
people as you've seen me over the last
couple of years so I will help people
get through the autumn in the winter as
I've done before and then we will make
the right reforms to help grow the
economy in the long term and I I don't
think the corporation is proposing more
money to help people of course I would
do you know how much we'll have to see
the size of the problem but look people
can see 13.3 inflation is what's
predicted yeah that's the size of the
problem and I don't want that to be
worse and I don't want it to last longer
so what I'm not going to do is embark on
a borrowing spree worth tens of billions
of pounds put that on the country's
credit card ask our kids and our
grandkids to pick up the tab because
that's not right it's not responsible
and it's certainly not conservative but
you're promising tax cuts without
knowing where inflation will be
I'm the one that's not standing here
sitting here now uh promising tens of
billions of pounds of unfundment what
you've actually said is no tax cuts
until inflation gets under control what
amounts to under control when it's on a
clearly downward trajectory and we we
have good line of sight that is
returning back to Target right okay
right but that doesn't but that's why we
need to be really careful about policies
that will make that worse right and look
I you know I if if that took the first
question uh it was you know I'm behind
in this race and I'm just a bit confused
so are you saying these income tax cuts
might not happen
you're talking about my longer term yes
of course I am yeah my longer term plan
I'm confident we can deliver it yes
right and that was the reason I
published that longer term plan and that
longer term plan for those watching was
to over time reduce income tax rates in
this country because I believe really
strongly in rewarding hard work hard
work is a value that I think is really
important I think most conservatives
share that view that hard work is
something that should be rewarded the
the best way to do that through the tax
system is to reduce the rate of income
tax and I wanted to give people a sense
of the direction of where I wanted to
take the country and the economy and I
want to build an economy where we cut
the rates of income tax over time and
we're going to do that not by asking our
kids to pick up the bill we're going to
do it by being disciplined on public
spending and performance well you're
very comfortable and you know exactly
what you think what we don't probably
know about is foreign affairs as much so
let me ask you about energy and food
bills and how that relates to Foreign
Affairs potentially how high do you
think that energy and food bills will
have to go before we reassess our
support for Ukraine
I don't I don't think that's how we're
going to look at it actually because we
can make an enormous difference over
between now and actually next winter in
reducing our dependence on Russian
energy so in the short term of course
we're going to step in and I want to
step in and help people more I announced
enormous support as Chancellor as prime
minister I'll go further because the
situation is deteriorated but what I'm
looking to is by next winter that we've
got through this and there's lots of
things we can do to help us do that so A
couple of examples right so so one thing
we can do is improve our energy storage
because actually we can import lots of
gas in the middle of the year no we
actually we can do that relatively
quickly improved energy storage during
the middle of the year but the other
thing we can do is Energy Efficiency now
many of you here many people watching
are living in homes where we can help
improve the insulation Loft insulation
cavity wall insulation smart temperature
controls those are relatively small
scale interventions that don't take very
long or cost a fortune and government
has got money but if we Turbo Charge
that program we can not only reduce you
saw demand for energy which improves our
energy security we can also save people
up to 300 pounds on their bills now
that's the type of thing that we should
continue to support Ukraine as long as
we like lag our loft is that what you're
saying we need to be lagging our Loft
anyway for climate change reasons right
because it's good to reduce our
long-term Demand on energy right but
what we do want to do is make sure we
help people with their bills and that's
a good example of something we can do on
the conflict in Ukraine Boris Johnson
has um really thrown himself into the
course I think everybody might agree
with that he's regarded as a hero
apparently in Ukraine that's what he
tells us he brandishes his missile
launches we've seen that are you really
tough enough to stand up to Vladimir
Putin well just think for a moment how
are we currently standing it's your hell
yeah moment yeah so how are we standing
up to Vladimir Putin right how are we
actually doing it we're doing two things
right we're sending arms and money to
Ukraine which as we talked about earlier
I found from elsewhere in government
spending so that we could free up that
money to send to president zielinski but
what's the other way we're weakening
Russia we're doing it through economic
sanctions right we're not sending our
troops into Russia right it's not
diplomatic measures that are making a
difference it's economic what are we
doing we're targeting his companies
their access to global Capital markets
his gold trading his Central Bank
Reserves that's how we're economically
turning the screw on Russia who do you
think put all those things together
I did with all my finance minister
colleagues around the world working with
a treasure secretary in America working
with European Finance ministers we
designed an international package of
economic sanctions that would send a
very strong message that we will not
stand for his aggression it's the most
stringent set of economic sanctions the
world has ever seen and it is making a
difference and as prime minister I will
go further because there's more things
we can do so yes I'm tough enough and
I'm already delivering the measures that
are actually causing him the most
trouble up thank you
uh Ben Wallace um as we I mentioned
before said that you had to be overruled
on defense spending pretty Patel the
Home Secretary reportedly said that you
objected to the Rwanda plan during a
written discussion between the
Departments Brandon Lewis the Northern
Ireland secretary former Northern
Ireland secretary has accused you of
putting up huge resistance on efforts to
override the Northern Ireland protocol
it looks as though there's a recurring
theme there doesn't there you say one
thing in private and then you say
something else for voter consumption so
should we believe then or should we
believe you well look when it comes to
the Rwanda plan I do believe in the
Rwanda policy but do I ask tough
questions when cabinet ministers come to
me and say oh look we like to do this
new thing yeah because my job is to make
sure that yours and everyone else
watching and everyone in this audience's
money is spent properly that's part of
my job I wouldn't be doing my job
properly if every time some cabinet
minister came to me and said oh please
can I have x billion pounds to do this
new thing I don't say well hang on let
me just check that this actually is
going to work is it worth our spending
taxpayers money 120 million pounds on
sending 200 people to Rwanda is good
value for money yeah well it's a pilot
right so the pilot bit is expensive so
you're asking now exactly the questions
I was asking so if pretty Patel or
anyone else is going to say oh now I
expressed some doubts about it it was
doubts about how we're going to make the
policy work I believe in the policy but
it's not good enough in government to
just announce things that's not good
enough to put out a press release it's
what you need to do is deliver things
and I think what people saw for me
during the pandemic as Chancellor that I
could deliver things I actually
delivered policies that worked and made
a difference which by the way were done
in record time and were Radical and I
will bring that same sense of grip and
urgency and competence to all these
other challenges whether it's the Rwanda
policy whether it's the NHS backlogs
okay let's talk about climate you
brought it up we're trying to whiz
through these topics as best we can
because obviously some of these people
have not got their ballot papers yet
some have and what you're telling them
both here in the studio and at home this
evening could make the difference as to
whether or not you are the next prime
minister of this country so let's talk
about the climate should we one issue
that affects not just our finances but
of course our future is
um your green credentials can I test
them
sure here we go new coal mines yes or no
they're local decisions but I don't
think we should be importing coal from
other places if we have it at home okay
what about fracking where there has the
support of local communities I'm in
favor of it okay but we have seen some
big issues with fracking haven't we
particularly in my part of the world in
the northwest of England where we've
seen at least three earthquakes that
apparently have been caused by fracking
yeah but we also as I said most poorly
it has to be done with the support of
local communities but we do also have a
study from I think I think three
different Royal societies I think of
geologists and engineers and and I can't
remember the third group but it's online
somewhere all of whom said that they
believe fracking is safe and the seismic
activity is not out of the ordinary
they're all the scientists who have came
to that conclusion not me but as I said
I'm supportive of it where we can bring
the local community along with us
because if we can get it to work it's
good for our long-term energy would you
raise flight taxes would I raise flight
taxes no why not well well because as
chance so I already made a change to
Airline taxation
yes it was actually because I did two
things one is I I reversed a European
rule that forced us to charge people
twice when they flew inside of the
United Kingdom on air passing Duty I
didn't think that was right and after we
left the EU we could say we're not going
to do that anymore if you fly around the
UK because we believe in a United
Kingdom it should only be taxed once but
at the same time I created a new band
for the longest Hall flights the most
polluting flights we created a brand new
band with a high level of tax so
actually it was balanced right so for
the people who are flying the farthest
with the more emissions they were going
to pay more for people flying within the
United Kingdom we took an advantage of
brexit on Shore wind yes or no because
I'm a bit confused on this so I'm not
offshore when onshore and forgive me yes
or no no okay you've changed your mind
no I haven't I just last night I was
asked a question I didn't fully
understand it and I misspoke but my
position on that is the same as it's
been okay how are we going to get to Net
Zero by 2050. with Innovation yeah and
the type of future economy that I want
to create is one where this and we
talked about it in the answer to the
Visa's question from someone uh if we
have an economy where this is the best
place in the world for people to create
invent discover new things we will get
there and we will get there in a way
that lowers people's bills now look my
business background my experience means
I know how to build that type of economy
in this we've got to rush through this
okay well that's what's important
there's an enormous opportunity if you
don't mind quick fire questions here we
go do you personally support the 24-week
limit on abortion uh as a personal thing
yes
I mean these These are these are
personal decisions they're not
government decisions
I don't think there's any need to change
the I believe in a woman's right to
choose I don't think there's any reason
to change the laws that we have why have
you abstained on every major vote on
abortion uh probably because I've not
been in Parliament on the day you didn't
think it was important enough to be
there because as Chancellor I'm often
traveling
2015 apparently were you Chancellor in
2015. uh no but I mean these are these
are not free I mean I completely agree
with our current system of abortion I
don't think it should be changed so if
the I mean so that's my general view
that's always been my view you just
haven't but you should have them in
there when the votes have been taking
place would you fist bump uh the Saudi
leader Muhammad bin Salman as Joe Biden
did I'm probably not a fist bumping type
of person I think probably shake his
hand then I mean yes I will shake his
hand I generally I think you do have to
engage with people around the world I
don't think and they're a country that
we have a relationship with
uh in a video here it comes from 2001
you said you didn't have any
working-class friends have you made any
working-class friends since you left
University I mean I I was I think I was
a student when I said that we all say
silly things when when we're younger I
mean at the same time I was as as you
know I was working in my mum's shop I
was out and about cycling around running
around delivering medicines to people
all people from all walks of life but
you know obviously I was a kid and I
said something silly so you do have
working class friends now yeah I mean I
don't go around asking them what they're
they're how they perform themselves
I'd rather think we've kind of moved I
think we've moved beyond that as a
country actually I reassure it yeah I
think people are less interested in
where you've come from people interested
in where you're going and that's the
kind of country I want to build right
where thank you yeah
let me ask you the same question that I
asked this trust about being prime
minister being the most invasive exposed
period in any politician's life anything
you want to tell us about
no I mean look I've had I've had a
relatively high profile job for two
years and I think people have seen me in
action and they've seen hey what I can
do they've seen a lot much of my
personal life has also been talked about
earlier this year and that was an
experience that I took uh you know that
I learned from and and dealt with so yes
I'm used to the scrutiny another simple
question have you ever benefited
financially from the use of tax Havens
no
a venture capital firm you co-founded
telman Partners was registered in the
Cayman Islands so just to clarify I I
personally
never ever benefited and have paid
absolutely full normal taxes wherever
I've lived did you set up that business
no okay so you you weren't a co-founder
in 2000 and not of the the bit in the
Cayman Islands that you're referring to
I have nothing to do with okay I mean I
happen to work with a company that has
multiple offices all around the all
around the world but that's not my
responsibility it was not running the
company so you weren't in any way paid
by that offshore company
when I was living in America I paid all
my taxes in America and when I've lived
in the UK I've paid all my taxes in the
UK completely as anyone else would Okay
the reason I'm asking is that as you
know as all our audience know you've had
to clarify your wife's non-dom status
you held permanent residency in the
United States while he was setting the
taxes of British voters which is what a
green card means
um you're building a swimming pool at
your constituency home while the public
pool in Richmond is facing closure after
a 400 Energy hike
this has all led to a perception problem
for you people feel that you can't walk
a mile in their shoes because you're
walking in your Prada shoes what would
you say to them
so you know over the past couple of
weeks right I've been out and about
across the country talking talk to
members talking to members of the public
and as I was saying lots of people have
come talk to me about that press
conference and furlough and what
difference it made to their lives do you
know I I was wearing the same suit in
that press conference the same shoes as
I'm wearing now right I'm the same
person how much were they worth yeah I'm
very slick I'm exactly the same person
right I'm the same person that stood
there and made sure that we helped the
country through a very difficult time
and that's what I'll do as prime
minister and I think the British people
judge people by their character and by
their actions not by their bank account
thank you
that certainly seems to be the case as
far as the audience is concerned here
but there's plenty of people who are
watching at home who would disagree with
that perception is reality and they
think that you're too rich to be prime
minister yeah well the reality is one of
the last things I did as Chancellor was
announce significant help for people
with their energy bills this ultimate
winter into the question we had at the
front from David I think it was right
that was David's question was about
helping the most vulnerable right people
who really needed help that's what I did
because look we're all going to have a
difficult time and and inflation makes
everyone poorer and that's why I'm so
concerned about policies that will make
it worse and last longer and that's not
right but when we do need to help people
this Autumn winter our focus should be
on the people who most need our help and
actually you know when Liz is sitting
here saying she's going to scrap the NHS
Levy do you know who that benefits that
benefits the top 15 of earners right
that's what that policy does it's not
going to help the people that David was
asking about with the cost of living
this winter right the policies I
announced as Chancellor are targeted on
those people because they are the people
that need our help right it's going to
be really tough it's going to be really
tough for lots of people and much as I
want to support them to work hard and do
those things right it's going to be just
impossible and we need to help them and
that's what I did you can't do all of
that on your own
um Penny mordant uh has backed uh Ms
trust Ben Wallace says it's trust Nadeem
zahawi is back mistrust Tom toukenheart
has backed uh Liz truss sagittarill boss
has backed Miss trust why are so many
people supporting her rather than you
right but but Kay goes back to the
question right at the beginning
every stage of the Parliamentary process
I had the broadest and biggest number of
support most closely with you and
they've decided that they prefer her
well hang on the most MPS in Parliament
and all MPS work together in lots of
different guises
and they said you know what actually Tom
two are going to happen are not in the
cabinet okay
um but every single round of the
Parliamentary programs I led
every round ahead of everyone else and
since it finished more and more people
have come and joined the team so I'm
actually I'm really humbled by that and
I'm delighted and actually as we're
answering a question that support is
drawn really widely from across the
Parliamentary party and and I'm not
going to get into who's going to have
this job and that job I've got a contest
that I want to try and win I want to be
out and about talking to all of you
about my ideas for the future but I will
build a team that reflects all the
talent and traditions of our party as I
said you saw a lot of that on display in
this leadership contest and as we talked
about before we're all one team we're
all one family we're going to come
together after this we're going to serve
the British people and I'm going to take
it to care storm and win the next
election because that's the real prize
final thought when you go you know when
you look at yourself in the mirror at
night just before you go to bed and you
think all these people that are sat
around the cabinet table with me and now
they don't want to work with me they
think that the other candidates better
but plenty of people sat around the
cabinet table also support me right
Dominic Robb the Deputy Prime Minister
is out there right now talking about it
and lots of others but I also as I said
no actually the question actually just
him I think I think we only just have
one person right yeah much as we love
you and we love Skye I think it's really
a tolerate just one person giving up
their evening to come and talk to you
later but you know I've been you know
I've been really harsh I've had to take
that actually I think I think he's the
perfect place to end thank you very much
indeed thank you very much so
so our candidates have had their chance
to make their case but what do the
people who will decide their future make
of it we have a simple question for our
audience are you ready audience we
rehearse this beforehand after what you
have heard tonight who are you most
likely to vote for as you know you need
to press one and then send if it's Rishi
sunak and you need to press two and then
send if it is Liz trust are we all ready
any more questions before we need to do
that everybody knows exactly what
they're going to say and do away you go
there we go so we have 15 seconds when
people were pressing one for Rishi sunac
or two for Liz truss and then pressing
pressing send and then as if by Magic in
just a few moments time we'll find out
what our audience here in the studio
thinks about who should be the next
prime minister of this country worth
just pointing at at this stage that 0.3
percent of the electorate will decide
our next prime minister which means 99.7
of the electorate will not be doing that
do you think that's fair yes yes why do
you think it's fair gentlemen here why
do you think it's fair
is the next prime minister we have a
parliamentary system people voted for
the conservative party as members we're
electing the leader it happens to be
that that leader becomes prime minister
this is a basic understanding of us okay
thank you gentlemen up here really
quickly with a check shirt yep yep it's
exactly the same as what labor do okay
when they chose um okay now as with all
things with live television the
technology has crashed
[Applause]
I do instead is go with a show a show of
hands instead are we happy with that
yeah so will you will you allow me to
say who I think has probably got more
hands thank you so if you think that
Rishi sunak had a better show and as a
result would potentially make the better
prime minister of this country can you
put your hand up now ladies and
Gentlemen please oh my goodness that
looks to me like an awful lot for Mr
sunac who would prefer mistrust as the
next prime minister now
I wasn't expecting that I have to say
but I think with just giving you hands
up for Miss Tross while we get some more
shots just to show people at home it
looks to me as though Mr sunac convinced
you far more than Miss chos
um I'm sorry sir we're almost out of
time and I have had you let you have a
couple of goals I think the only thing
that you probably need to learn from
tonight is to read a bit of Shakespeare
I don't know what you think
anyway it's been fantastic to see you
all thank you so much for taking the
time for joining us thank you also to Ms
trust and also uh to Mr sunak they were
amazing thank you very much indeed for
joining us I really really appreciate it
very very enlightening conversation and
discussion from both of them coming up
in just a few moments time Jane's second
will be talking to both uh Mr kwarting
and also Mr Rob and I will see you very
soon good evening thank you for joining
us
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much okay well there you
have it the battle for number 10.
there's truss and Rishi sunak answering
questions from our studio audience made
up of conservative party members lots
and lots to chew through lots of really
interesting points let's get some
instant reaction to what we've just seen
and heard our Deputy political editor
Sam Coates is with me here Sam what for
you is the biggest headline of the night
well wasn't that fascinating because
what I think we had tonight was the most
challenging the most in-depth grilling
that those two candidates have had so
far on the campaign Trail and what set
it apart was this wasn't just narrowly a
contest this wasn't a a debate or a set
of issues just answering the concerns of
touring members this covered the whole
the whole gamut of issues of concern uh
to the nation for whoever uh wins this
contest becomes prime minister in a
month and two days and what was
fascinating is you saw really the two
candidates weak spots explodes pretty
ruthlessly I thought by um Cape early
and and they were different things so
with Liz truss what you heard time and
again was an attempt to push back at the
way that she would make promises or she
would defend what a point sounded like
some pretty hard positions that she got
into so uh one of the most eye-catching
moments of that debate of that encounter
uh was when she was asked what she'd do
to help people in the cost of living
crisis and she said I will do all I can
now that's not a commitment that we've
heard before she caveat it by saying
well uh based on what I can afford but
that kind of broad brush promise looks
until now to have gone down incredibly
well with the party uh and that's what's
catapulted apparently into the lead but
at the same time uh she was clearly
happy to make promises unclear quite
where some of the money was coming for
billions potentially uh to try and look
again at doctors pensions and she found
herself being challenged by the audience
on sound money let's hear some of what
Liz truss ended up saying to Kay Burley
well what the bank of England have said
today is of course extremely worrying
but it is not inevitable we can change
the outcome and we can make it more
likely that the economy grows but what I
can assure UK is I will do all I can to
help people who are struggling with the
cost of living I understand that people
are going through difficult times and if
there are any more available resources
of course I would put that to helping
people with the cost of living you said
that public sector pay policy has been
misrepresented by the media here's the
proposals that you released introduce
Regional paid boards tailoring pay to
the cost of living where civil servants
actually work saving up to 8.8 billion
pounds per year so how have we
misrepresented you so far well what what
I am clear about is that policy was not
about teachers and doctors but can I be
clear Kay that I'm not going ahead with
this because you said I'm just
clarifying because because of the
concerns that have been expressed okay
and when something is just clarified
when there's an issue okay I deal with
it okay but just to clarify whether
you're misrepresented or not you
highlighted a very specific saving 8.8
billion pounds how did you reach that
figure well I don't have the details I
can tell you okay there are no skeletons
in my closet I think everything I've
ever said and done is known about very
publicly
what was so interesting about the way
that uh Liz truss responded under the
spotlight is we're challenged she would
dig in and dig in not necessarily
offering any more information uh but
when challenge she refused to apologize
on that public sector pay Gaff where you
just saw her being challenged over claim
that the media misrepresented but then
be unable to explain that challenged
overwatched the you turn on British
fighters to Ukraine she just said uh she
never admitted really to making a
mistake on restoring trust as you just
heard her say there are no skeletons in
her closet there was a rider that aren't
already known will that come back to
haunt her we don't know we asked both
candidates that it's the Eternal
question for politicians but
interestingly she refused to commit to a
new ethics advisor uh necessarily
appointed a new ethics advisor I think
what we got from this truss is somebody
who like Boris Johnson can be stubborn
like Boris Johnson doesn't back down
what we got from Rishi sunak was
something very different what he faced a
challenge on was his record personal and
political let's hear a bit of how he was
forced to defend the help out to eat out
scheme
you were also the chancellor that
introduced eat out to dial out at a cost
of 850 million pounds and according to
the University of Warwick that was
responsible for an increase of new
covert cases of between eight and
Seventeen percent
well actually that's one study that said
that and I don't think it's right
we need to change the definition of
asylum and move away from this European
definition which has become very broad
it's exploited by Lefty lawyers and
means it's very hard to remove people
fundamentally we must get a grip of this
we have to make the Rwanda policy work I
will do whatever it takes including
legal changes if required to make it
work
you've been campaigning for a long time
and it was perfectly timed a cynical
motivation to try and get you into
number 10. no so that's that's just
simply not true so I was due to give a
speech with the Prime Minister the next
week and in the conversations about
putting that speech together on the
economy it was clear our differences
were too big to reconcile okay so that
was the reason plus I think let's not
look at the bus with rose tinted
spectacles here everyone remembers what
was going on with Chris pincher right
that that was a serious ethical question
that the government was on the wrong
side of again
I'm the same person that stood there and
made sure that we helped the country
through a very difficult time and that's
what I'll do as prime minister and I
think the British people judge people by
their character and by their actions not
by their bank account
[Applause]
and what's really amazing Jane about all
of those bits of the Rishi sunak
grilling is that here we have somebody
who is a relatively short-lived
Chancellor as they go repeatedly being
forced to defend his record whether it
was Diddy knife Boris Johnson while in
the job or whether or not he's his
stewardship of the economy is now
responsible for such high inflation now
if you look at his rival Liz truss is
the longest serving cabinet minister yet
it's Richie sunac for whom his record is
the issue that audience members and
questions by Kay Burley repeatedly came
back to Rishi sinak's inheritance I
think was the thing that came under the
spotlight the most today I think it was
Liz trust plans for the future has
stubbornness that was really highlighted
in the last 90 minutes okay Sam thanks
very much for that snap into analysis
well we've also got the two
representatives of the two candidates
who we spoke to earlier they've stayed
behind to react to it for Russia sunak
we have Dominic Robb the Deputy Prime
Minister and Justice secretary and for
his trust we have the business secretary
quasi corteng and uh Dominic Rob can I
come to you first just just because we
just had that audience vote there at the
end at the national uh polls amongst
conservative leaders put Liz trust well
ahead but but clearly in that audience
vote at the end there he he did enough
to win people over were you surprised
that so many people in the audience
appeared to to be won over by Rishi
sunak
now I wasn't uh and I think first of all
in terms of the arguments by the way I
thought it was a good debate and both
candidates uh quitted themselves well
and I thought the format was useful for
teasing out the real issues but I just
felt Rishi was more credible on the
economy more compelling when it comes to
the issue of uniting the party and
actually in that bit at the end where
they all both candidates face tricky
questions he responded very strongly and
as we saw I think he got the two
candidates the most Applause and I think
by something like 75 percent one uh won
the the the show of hands in the
audience and the truth is the more
people see Rishi sunak the more
compelling and the more they warmed
towards him and the more that this
contest will go our way
we don't know how these voters felt
beforehand we know that the majority of
them said to us that they were undecided
um but but do you think that that this
trust perhaps didn't quite hit the Mark
tonight
look I think she did a good job but I
think where she was very fluent uh but
where and he was slick but where are I
where I disagree with him was on the
fundamentals of what he said I don't
believe that you grow an economy by
raising taxes he made the point that the
recession was caused by the inflation
but why would you increase taxes if
people are suffering from uh the cost of
living He also said something which Ben
Wallace uh directly questioned a week
ago in relation to the defense
settlement Rishi claimed that it was
entirely his uh doing but Ben suggested
that the Prime Minister might have had a
hand uh in that so there were a number
of things and of course there was the
question about his loyalty and his
support for the Prime Minister I think
Rishi did a good job in answering that
but these are the kinds of doubts that
many people many of our members uh have
and it was very good that they were
aired I think Rishi did well he answered
many of those uh challenges uh
effectively but these are the kinds of
questions that are going to keep
cropping up and it's very fair that they
should do so Liz truss um she did dig in
Assam Coast is pointing out to lots of
the questions she was asked by the
audience and by K not willing to
apologize not willing to to to
Really grow back on it on many things
that she had said do you think that is
the right strategies that there's those
who will say it's good to be confident
in your beliefs but you also don't want
to come across as being too strident
well she's she's not strident at all
actually the thing that she was
questioned about most by Kay was uh the
original pay and she said that that was
something uh that she felt uh she had to
act quickly and decisively she's a very
sincere politician she's straightforward
according to her own words she's not as
slick as many other presenters but she's
sincere she's honest she's hard working
and I think she'll be a fabulous prime
minister
why do you think Rishi sunax record is
something that that people seem so Keen
to scrutinize salmon Coates were saying
you know he has been a Chancellor for a
relatively short period of time uh yet
and a lot has happened during that
period of time it has to be said yet
there is a great deal of focus and a
great deal of scrutiny on on what he has
done
being Chancellor the exchequer is the
second biggest job in government and
after being prime minister and to to be
honest with you I thought the most
comfortable moments for Rishi was when
he got the chance to answer why he took
the measures he did to help people
through the pandemic the 12 million jobs
that were were saved as a result of that
uh unprecedented intervention in
response to unprecedented times uh how
he's got the economy going and what his
plans are for the future
um so I think I think in politics you
expect a combination of being have your
records scrutinized but also your plans
for the future and I thought he dealt
with that grilling particularly well and
that shows I think he's thought things
through he didn't get hung up in the
same way as Liz did on a reversal of a
pay uh Regional pay policy that had just
been announced because he thinks things
through and I think that's a an
important characteristic in a prime
minister particularly at this time when
there are so many risks around with
relation with interest rates and I think
that just re reinforced his credibility
well we thank you both so much for
coming along this evening and staying
long after the discussion you started
with him and then ended with him so I'm
very very good I had the last word very
briefly no I just want to say very
quickly that Liz is not the slickest
presenter she said that but she's
sincere hard working and trustworthy and
that's what we've got to remember we've
got to have someone that we can trust
and that can be trusted to deliver and
this is that person
let it not be said that we are not
even-handed question and Dominic thank
you both very much indeed
well let's just see how Tory supporters
out in the country feel about what they
have heard this evening got a sense from
the audience what they thought but let's
go to Mari Aurora she is up there in
Worcester and has been engaging reaction
there Murray which candidate seems to to
win over the voters where you are and
what do they think about how both
performed
well it's still a very mixed bag I would
say the Liz trust supporter seem to be
have kind of solidified their support
for this trust but she soon act
supporters similar and some undecided
supporters now veering towards you know
but let me take you over here so we can
speak to them so to start with this is
Adele she's a Liz trust supporter so why
are you sticking with Liz after watching
that debate well I think they both
perform really well Rish is obviously a
very slick performer
um he's he speaks very strongly on the
economy and he said the economy is the
most important thing I'm not sure I
agree with him I think there are other
things are just as important
um you know the issues that we've got in
our health care and when he I mean his
argument with that one because he's less
strong on on that area was to issue this
fine for people who don't attend
appointments and I think that that will
affect the poorest and most vulnerable
in society unfairly where Liz said that
the money they got ring fenced full
social care that she would direct
through to the social care because
there's a big backlog there and I
thought that was a more convincing
argument for me that's just one of the
things you know the substance of what
they had to say so yeah I'll still be
with Liz truss I think yeah okay so
Adele they're not convinced by rishi's
unex promises around the NHS now if we
speak to Christine and George over here
they both were undecided and are now
convinced by Rishi sunak So Christine
tell me why but she's gonna run you over
I think Richie sooner came over as very
strong
very principled I'm very honest and I
think that's what the public need is a
politician who they can trust I think
you can trust him with the economy he's
had a great experience
with the economy he's been very good
Chancellor he's looked after people
during the pandemic which seems to be
glossed over the cost of the pandemic by
the general public and I think he would
make a fine prime minister I think he's
he's not phased by difficult questions
um let's trust I thought did very well
but
um to me she's a good trade Minister
um I just can't see her as being a
strong enough prime minister I don't
think she's got the experience and the
drive I think I think sorry no we can
see Christine not convinced by Liz trust
there I just want to squeeze in one more
voter before we leave so Mark over here
it's still not convinced by either why
are you still on the fence Mark well I
think both of them are excellent
actually I think they're both
appointable I think they both beat
kierstama and I was particularly pleased
to hear Liz trust tonight because I was
just a bit worried that whether she was
strong enough to do that and she's
convinced me that if she gets it she
will do a great job I knew Rishi was a
great performer and I think both of them
either of them now will will do uh we'll
keep the conservative flag flying high
okay so as you can see here in Worcester
still very much all to play for but what
I would say is we've had so many people
on the fence here I'm just going to ask
very quickly this room put your hands up
if you're now voting for Rishi sunak
put your hands up if you're voting for
Liz Truss
and put your hands up if you still don't
know
okay as you can see almost an even split
so we still don't know in Worcester uh
back to you in the studio
what more can we do Murray how many more
questions can we ask for them uh Mario
there thanks so much in Worcester
well let's get some snap analysis from
our Three Special correspondents Helen
Ann Smith on business and the economy oh
she's Joshi on the NHS and social care
and Thomas Moore on climate change and
before the debate we asked your what you
thought was going to feature what you
thought was going to be important Helen
Anne
given what we've heard today from the
bank of England
the cost of living was it was a big
thing that you thought would feature but
but what do you think you heard any
solutions well really interestingly I
think there was a big opportunity for
the candidates to really show that they
grasped the gravity of the moment and
really understood the severity of the
crisis that people are going to face
this winter and there was a lot of big
arguments weren't there about tax and
growth and a lot of these arguments we
have heard before they're quite well
trodden but there was almost nothing
about very specific targeted packages of
measures that frankly are going to be
needed this winter based on what the
bank of England said today a long
recession spiraling inflation energy
bills three times what they were last
winter and and I think it's debatable
whether either of them really sort of on
show that they truly understood just how
very serious it's going to be for some
families this winter very well trodden
arguments about tax and growth and we
can argue about those but but I was
surprised that there wasn't anything a
bit more specific a bit more agile okay
what about the NHS Richardson like of
course again talked about his Heritage
within the NHS is dad being a doctor as
mum being a pharmacist he talked about
missed appointments but did you think
there could have been more about about
the NHS I could definitely have been
more about the NHS I think this was a
missed opportunity for both candidates I
think NHS trust leaders will look at
this debate this evening and say nothing
was said to address the problems that
exist already and the problems which are
coming to the NHS further down the line
nothing pledged no more new money
nothing to address the workforce issues
Liz truss talked about the efficiencies
within the system so did Rishi sunak
they talked about the existing money
that's already earmarked by the Health
and Social care Levy and most people
have looked at Rishi sanak's idea about
10 pound fines for missed GP
appointments that will not solve the NHS
crisis so it was an opportunity for both
of them to really address what is
happening in the NHS and social care
sector I think both failed finally let's
talk climate change with Thomas Moore
and beforehand we said we weren't sure
whether it would be a really big concern
for many members of the audience Liz
trust didn't really get challenged about
it at all did she she didn't no but she
did in the context of both energy
security and indeed energy bills talk
about oil and gas from the North Sea
twice and I think that will concern many
environmentalists that her go-to on both
occasions is fossil fuels not solar and
wind which is where the country has been
going up to this point now Richie sunac
was grilled more on this and many
environmentalists will be encouraged
that he did talk about home energy and
efficiency home insulation and so on
that he did give a commitment to netzer
in terms of innovation but they will be
concerned that he still talks about uh
coal mining here in the UK as a source
of energy that again is the dirtiest
fuel at dirt's source of of carbon
dioxide and fossil fuels and that will
cause some concern okay well thank you
all three of you really interesting to
to get your thoughts of things you were
specifically listening in out for this
evening well let's see what some of our
studio audience made of it they sat
through it all they got up close and
personal uh with the politicians they
got a chance to ask some pretty uh
specific questions to them or political
correspondent Tamara Cohen has caught up
with a few of them now tomorrow
hi Jane yes I'm here with some of our
audience who were listening in as they
try to make their decisions Richie sunac
or Liz truss and I'm going to introduce
you to a few of them and hear what
they've got to say and first of all I've
got Zaid from Birmingham Zaid were you
leaning in any particular direction and
did tonight change things for you no no
I was undecided I was undecided but
tonight I think performance wise Rishi
I'd go with Rishi but still I think
we've still got a couple of weeks left
um Liz could again form even better so
you'll be waiting it out to make your
choice definitely and what on what
particular issues was Rishi the I mean
he obviously feels very comfortable on
the economy was that was that it for you
I think I think he knows the detail
um of course he was Chancellor for two
years but but he knows the detail more
um and the questions that was coming as
well economy I think he was responding
really well really quickly as well and
where do you think Liz Tross fell down
for you if she did it all uh not really
I don't think she fell down in any
matter but I think in terms of details I
said I think Rishi mastered it a lot
more I think but maybe because he was a
Chancellor so uh and Liz wasn't and Mary
um you are Mary's a care manager from
London and you were very impressed with
what Liz truss was saying on social care
yep I thought that she said something
different from what she said before she
wants a lot more money going into social
care today that's why I voted for her
tonight because that's my feel and I
know what people are facing out there
yeah because there's been a lot of
criticism of her not wanting to raise
National Insurance to pay for the NHS
but you thought that she made it clear
what she was actually going to do
tonight yeah did you think were you
thinking before tonight that you weren't
sure what her plans were yeah I wasn't
sure but she made it clear today the way
she's gonna tackle the social
and I was so impressed also I voted for
her tonight and so she she gets it you
think yes she gets it but what do you
fear that with these tax cuts that she
might not have the money left I mean
inflation is is rising isn't it well I
no doubt but I know she would deliver
she will keep to her promise yeah so you
feel you feel that she's she's the one
for you and and Richie each bill doesn't
have that strong well strong emphasis
I mean he didn't mention it tonight so
that's why and my aim here it was that
particular interesting and uh Lottie
what did you what did you make of it um
who was the winner for you well I think
just based on their performance tonight
um Rishi put on a better show
um I think he gives very straightforward
answers which I think is quite important
uh considering the past couple of years
of politics I think he can restore
integrity and Trust because that's so
important isn't it in this contest well
I think either winner needs to do that
uh there's not really a question about
that
um but I just think that uh Rishi seems
like he has a bit of a party within
Westminster behind him and I'm hoping
that in 2024 he potentially will gain
their lecture he gets stick Disney from
some members saying you unite Boris
Johnson we didn't want to get rid of
Boris Johnson and you bled that is that
an issue for you and for you Claire as
well did was that is that an issue for
you with Rishi sunak
um not particularly uh we've seen that
done in the past before Boris did it uh
himself I think so uh it's I I'm more
focused on on the policies uh I think
tonight he was quite for you he was he
was quite clear uh about looking at what
was happening at the time with the
Pinscher case uh and he just couldn't
take anymore so I think he was right so
standifying clarifying that are
important you feel he would he would
restore standards
um and and what about on the sort of
policy issues did you feel that Liz
trust fell down on anything or there was
anything you didn't know about her that
you found out tonight
uh I thought uh trust had some very
fresh ideas in terms of especially the
investment zones and things that young
people really care about in terms of uh
fixing the planning system and and
trying to create uh more homeowners and
more people with
who kind of can afford a house so a lot
of you were telling us that um there's
one one issue on which you didn't know
what you see neck thought what was that
well I do think the whole abortion thing
that was brought to light today
um has kind of not like I mean obviously
he made a good case I understand that
when you're trying to play around we're
running out of time that's really
interesting thank you all for talking to
us tonight now back to you Jane
thanks very much Tamara well uh let's
have a final chat with our Deputy
political editor Sam Coates so Sam this
is the last of the big official
discussions with the media and these two
candidates where does it leave us in
this campaign well I think tonight we
really got a sense of what this race is
about look to characterize it it was Mr
sensible versus the disrupter the
traitor versus the Boris Johnson
loyalist predictable versus
unpredictable look as we saw from the
show at hands at the end of that debate
where she seen that won the room he was
probably smoother but there are also
more challenges and a more nervous
moments I thought with Liz truss her
inability sometimes to explain to
apologize to characterize why she's
ended up doing what she's done damaged
her amongst the people that looked up
close but all the way through this race
people in the conservative party who've
been weighing up what Rishi sunak did in
government and how he behaved at the end
versus Liz truss just The View I think
of Boris Johnson amongst many of the
conservative party membership they're
enduring fundus for him still plays a
big place and has a big place in this
leadership contest Sam thanks very much
well what an interesting evening it has
been that is all from us here in this
studio after a special program on the
battle for number 10 where we heard that
Liz truss said the predicted recession
is not inevitable she wouldn't apologize
to Nicholas sturgeon whilst Rishi sunak
won over the Sky News audience Jillian
Joseph's coming up next with lots more
analysis
[Music]
foreign
[Music]